Clark what's wrong honey
it's bigger than you expected smaller
when I think back about Christmas
vacation the thing that amazes me was
the cast it was an incredible cast it
was heavy of course Randi of course
Johnny Galecki played rusty Juliette
Lewis played Audrey the biggest part of
that cast though were the older actors
because the actors that came on as the
in-laws and the grandparents and uncles
aunts and all that kind of stuff with a
real deal and I attribute that to
Jeremiah chechik in his in his direction
and bringing in eg Marshall Doris
Roberts Diane Ladd that was really a
special cast I don't want to tell them
what a cheap lying no-good rotten
four-flushing lowlifes you know when we
shot the scene in Christmas vacation
where Clark turns a switch and finally
does turn on the lights of the house I
know we were surrounded by artificial
snow and it was about 80 degrees and I
remember thinking is this stuff
flammable I think that that you know the
stress that I felt when I first wanted
to like oh let's do the biggest
Christmas in the world because I had
kids I think that Christmas vacation is
really about that and it's about how
everybody kind of has in the back of
their mind this is going to be horrible
but maybe it'll be great and they do
everything that they're supposed to do
with that wish that it's going to be
fantastic and of course in the Griswold
Ian universe everything that can go
wrong does go wrong but we always
persevere and we get there in the end
through love no matter what faith you
are no matter what brings you to
appreciate the happy chaos of Christmas
vacation I'm wishing you a merry holiday
season and I hope you enjoy every minute
of Christmas vacation when you get a
chance look at it really it's beautiful
some melt unrest yeah dad isn't a beaut
Audrey she'll see it later honey her
eyes are frozen